good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 29 7 t 8
object class safe special containment
procedures all instances of scp-2932
biometrically locked chamber the
containment chamber and all SCP 29 7 t 8
communities within are to be observed at
all times using high-speed HD camera
surveillance and digital microscope
systems access is limited to level 2
staff no storage peripherals exceeding
128 megabytes in size are to be inserted
into any SCP 29 7 t 8 a instance should
populations of SCP 29 7 t 8 be increased
to over SCP 29 7 t 8 a capacity
additional sections of compatible
hardware are to be added to prevent
overpopulation events addendum 28 79 to
following tests 2978 23 a second
biometrically secured entrance has been
added outside the primary containment
cell additionally no wireless networking
peripherals are permitted for use with a
CP 2978 description SCP 2978 consists of
two anomalies SCP 29 7 t 8 a and SCP
2978 b CP 2978 8 is a collection of
anomalously modified intel d 9 for 5g c
PE micro ATX motherboards normally found
in Intel Pentium 4 personal computers
anomalous properties are only apparent
when examined in close proximity all
components of the motherboards are
modified to function as a miniaturized
urban city environment
all USB ports of SCP 29 7 T 8a were
occupied by brand 256 megabytes USB
drives
when recovered these thumb drives have
resisted all attempts at removal thus
far number of thumb drives reduced see
event 2978 beta SCP 29 7 T 8 B are a
race of silicon-based humanoid
individuals measuring 400 to 500
micrometers in height and weighing 50 to
80 micrograms variably all SCP 29 7 T 8
B have a green skin tone with no visible
hair however each individual has a
unique physical appearance behavior and
personal life within the SCP 2978
community SCP 29 7 ta be emulated human
society with technology analogous to the
1990s individuals use a modified version
of english for communication and do not
need sustenance SCP 2978 b have a
lifespan of approximately 90 hours this
includes birth schooling careers
reproduction family life and death
high-speed camera equipment is required
to observe individuals daily lives a CP
2978 b seemed incapable perceiving
humans the exception being an individual
named our Father hereafter referred to
as person of interest 2978 SCP 29 7 t 8b
can however be physically interacted
with causing various detrimental effects
to their perceived normalcy references
to person of interest 2978 appear in
media and religious depictions in a-c-p
2978 communities
once compatible hardware makes physical
contact with an SCP 2970 a instance it
will be converted into an SCP 2978 a bi
SCP 29 7 t 8b individuals with an 11 to
15 hours depending on complexity
hardware manufactured after 20 does not
seem to be affected by a CP 2978
a's modifications current theories are
that SCP 29 7 t 8 instances have a set
software version only updated by the
creator of SCP 29 7 t 8 this would have
stopped after 20 the year of containment
all communities are named mother burg
with the suffix version 1 point X added
to each new iteration on all SCP 29 7 T
8 8 instances the following will be
printed on an upright transistor located
near the edge of the motherboard welcome
to mother Berg population variable as of
April 10th 20 mother Berg version 1
point is the last community to have been
built no power source is utilized for
the function of SCP 29 7 T 8 report on
event 2978
beta on the 24th of December 2015
junior researcher mil burro was seen
commencing daily observations of note he
had not informed staff that he had been
experiencing a head lice infestation
after concluding observation
surveillance footage shows him
scratching his scalp as he leaves
containment digital microscope footage
shows numerous SCP 29 7 t 8b individuals
playing an area of SCP 29 7 t 8 a 24
intercepted media from SCP 29 7 T 8
shows local news reporting on the
appearance of monsters encouraging
community members to flee to a CP 2978
25 after moving the position of SCP 29 7
T 8 24 digital microscope three
particular Shu Manas capitis head louse
are seen crossing the objects surface
five minutes after contact all a CP 2978
B individuals have evacuated SCP 29 7 T
8 24 due to the unexpected nature of the
event numerous SCP 29 7 t 8 a 25
structures served the secondary purpose
of a makeshift dwelling researcher
Edelsten expressed interest in the
preceding events and obtained site
director permission to continue
observation in the following hour the
first increases in birth rates were
observed possibly caused by overcrowding
neighboring SCP 29 7 ta communities
expressed disinterest in allowing the
immigration of SCP 29 7 t b--
individuals two hours after event 2978
beta began living space had become a
serious problem and births had increased
further neighboring SCP 29 7 t 8 8
communities enacted border patrols which
prevented emigration causing hostility
at the four hour mark the lyse still
present on SCP 29 7 T 8 24 were seen
behaving as typical to their species
with a single louse moving towards SCP
2978 25 no attempts of their removal
have been made living space and
resources had now become critical
problems on a CP 2978 25 with rioting
and violence becoming a common
occurrence at this point a small group
of SCP 29 7 T 8 B individuals was sent
to SCP 29 7 ta 24 the group is seen
moving towards the thumb drive on SCP 29
7 T 8 24 after reaching their
destination two individuals are seen
entering the storage peripheral
three seconds after entering an
explosion occurs in containment
the explosion obliterates SCP 29 7 T 8
24 and damages three additional
communities causing SCP 29 7 T 8 B
deaths all headlights are destroyed in
the explosion researcher Edelsten
received minor trauma to the face and
neck caused by shrapnel mass hysteria
was observed following in the event
during which three new motherboards were
introduced to SCP 29 7 t 8 a for
conversion these new motherboards were
placed in SCP 29 7 ta 24s former
location and in close proximity of
communities affected by the explosion
version events occurred as per normal
and repopulation proceeded smoothly over
the following 12 hours prayers and
offerings to person of interest 2978
increased exponentially over the
following few days thanking them for
their new dwellings after the described
events it has been determined that all
thumb drives have been modified with an
explosive of unknown origin these
devices are most likely reserved for
emergency situations and are not to be
tampered with outside influence
resulting in mass panic is therefore
actively discouraged containment
procedures have been updated attempts of
communication with a CP 2978
b
on 20 researchers printed a microscopic
message on a grain of rice the message
contained three questions the responses
were printed on a piece of prism shaped
silicon placed near the grain of rice
the responses were penned by the leader
of SCP 29 7 th question when were you
created answer o our Father a joying
occasion your words grace our optics
view all-knowing must be testing us for
surely for you are the Creator we will
respond to the or debug nevertheless err
I was born on the 55th cycle in 245 b8
during the second flash but our worlds
were born when the or servants awoke to
45 B 8 switches ago question who is your
Creator answer most grace having view
forgotten us
we know the you every cycle of every
switch since our birth you are our
Creator our father King of Kings our
reason for birth and death
having view come to take us all to the
virgin does our response be your
satisfaction it has been EF 88 switches
since your last debug why does the you
communicate with us in this manner
question what is your purpose answer our
purpose greatest and only is to live
through the your word and be worthy for
the father board as the final switch
come where our second version be
realized is it now for we will be ready
the area where the grain of rice was
placed was flooded with activity over
the next few hours and has since became
a place of religious significance zhu SE
p 2978 be individuals being the most
visited of all SE p 2978 a locations all
communication has since been ceased
transcript of incident 2970 a1 during
tests 2978
23 forward researcher Edelsten is
testing conversion of non compatible
hardware with a CP 2978 a 14th of
september 20
18:47 researcher Edelsten is seen
inserting generic brand of mobile
broadband modem into a USB port on a CP
2978 8 the latest iteration tested USB
port is noted to function as a bus
station for SCP 29 7 T 8 a 1850
researcher Edelsten finishes prepping of
test and leaves containment chamber 1855
microscopic imaging indicates increased
movements of SCP 29 7 t 8b individuals
in the area 1941 no changes on mobile
router SCP 2970 media shows increased
attention to the inserted router 1959
first drastic changes in SCP 29 7 t 8
stock exchange noted with tech company
mother tech stock prices increasing by a
thousand percent 16th of september 2015
1350 for unknown modifications appear on
wireless router 13 57 attempt is made to
contact researcher Edelsten he is
unavailable but notified of progress
telephone conversation indicates him
ordering junior researchers to keep
testing active until his arrival 14 32
hundreds of SCP 29 7 t 8b individual's
observed to enter tested USB port
containing router 14 33 junior
researcher matthews enters containment
intending to halt current test 14 33
wireless modem ejects from USB port
traveling at 18 km/h modem now referred
to as SCP 29 7 t 8 a alpha
14:34 SCP 29 7 t 8 a alpha appears to be
an areal exploration vehicle piloted by
a CP 2978 be individuals method of
propulsion is unknown it is observed by
high-speed cameras circling the
containment area once an escaping
containment 1435 containment breach
alarm is activated SCP 29 7 T 8a alpha
is seen traveling at 20 km/h through
site hallways 1436 SCP 29 7 T 8a alpha
is seen entering ventilation ducts 14:38
visual contact with SCP 29 7 T 8 a alpha
is lost SCP 2978 a alphas current
whereabouts are unknown sight white
sweeps have been inconclusive
disciplinary action has been taken
against SCP 29 7 t 8 research team
researcher Edelsten has been reprimanded
for his actions a statement is observed
on the noun disused USB port it reads
our father's gift a vessel for the O's
brave enough to find him and it in life
containment procedures updated SCP 29 7
T 8 was found in the home with
discredited by Oh engineer dr. stone
after a fire almost destroyed his
residence a total number SCP 29 7 t 8 8
instances were destroyed in the fire
SCP 2978 be deaths SCP 29 7 t 8 media
covered the event for 3 months and a
memorial plaque was erected on SCP 2978
a1 its community
dr.p current whereabouts are unknown
and that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andrey Pichette dr.
mortis Cody tench Pierce M Hamlin sy7
actual rebellion fidelia's untie verbal
if you would like a personalized thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]